>>> WOW.
SECRETARY YELLEN, IT WAS AN
HONOR TO HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY.
>> WELL, IT WAS MY PLEASURE,
PROFESSOR.
IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO SPEAK TO
ASPIRING ECONOMISTS.
>> DO WE HAVE TIME FOR ONE MORE
QUESTION?
>> HEY, I DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE TO
BE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ANYONE HAVE A
QUESTION?
COME ON, GUYS.
THE SECRETARY OF TREASURY IS
RIGHT NEXT TO US.
♪♪♪
>> UH, YES, YOU, YOUNG MAN.
♪ TWO SILICON BOYS
WERE TALKING OUTSIDE
TALKING OUTSIDE
TALKING OUTSIDE ♪
>> OKAY.
AND?
SO WHAT IS YOUR QUESTION?
♪ TWO SILICON BOYS
WERE TALKING OUTSIDE
TALKING OUTSIDE
TALKING OUTSIDE ♪
>> UH, YEAH, I HEARD YOU THE
FIRST TIME.
♪ NA NA NA NA NA NA
NOW WHAT THE
HELL'S AN NFT
APPARENTLY CRYPTOCURRENCY ♪
♪ EVERYONE'S MAKING
SO MUCH MONEY
CAN YOU PLEASE EXPLAIN
WHAT'S AN NFT ♪
♪ I SAID WHAT THE HELL'S
AN NFT IT'S LIKE REAL
LIFE MONOPOLY
EVERYONE IS DOING ♪
♪ IT LIKE GRONKOWSKI
CAN YOU PLEASE HELP
ME MAKE AN NFT ♪
>> SON, I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND A
WORD YOU JUST SAID.
>> HEY, THANKS.
>> THAT IS NOT A COMPLIMENT.
>> I DISAGREE.
>> I ACTUALLY SEE WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING, YOUNG MAN.
WE ARE AWARE OF NFTs, AND THEY
ARE CURRENTLY --
>> EXCUSE ME.
I CAN BREAK IT DOWN FOR YOU.
>> I'M SORRY, ARE YOU MORPHEUS
FROM THE "MATRIX" FILM SERIES?
>> NO, BUT I DO HAVE PILLS IF
YOU NEED SOME.
ANYWAY.
THE THING ABOUT NFTs IS --
♪♪♪
♪ NOW I CAN BUY ME A GIF ♪
♪ LOOK AT THESE IF YOU PLEASE
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE ♪
♪ HEY HERE'S A THANOS AT WORK ♪
♪ FOR $24 MILLION IT COULD BE
YOURS ♪
♪ AND THE PRICES GO UP AND DOWN
YOU SEE ♪
♪ SO THAT EXPLAINS AN NFT ♪
>> OKAY, WELL THAT WAS JUST A
LIST OF COMPLETE NONSENSE.
BUT YOU'RE NOT TOTALLY WRONG.
CAN ANYONE HERE EXPOUND ON THAT
A BIT MORE ELOQUENTLY?
ANYONE?
WHAT ABOUT YOU, MAN WITH THE
MOP?
>> WHO, ME?
WELL, I WASN'T REALLY PAYING
ATTENTION, BUT IF I HAD TO
EXPLAIN NFTs I'D PROBABLY SAY --
♪ HEY HERE'S THE THING
ABOUT NFTs IT'S
A NON-FUNGIBLE TOKEN
YOU SEE ♪
♪ NON-FUNGIBLE MEANS
THAT IT'S UNIQUE
THERE CAN ONLY
BE ONE LIKE YOU ♪
♪ AND ME
NFTs ARE INSANE
BUILT ON A
BLOCK CHAIN ♪
♪ A DIGITAL LEDGER
OF TRANSACTIONS
IT RECORDS INFORMATION ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING ♪
♪ WHEN IT'S MINTED
YOU CAN SELL
IT AS ART
AND THIS CONCLUDES ♪
♪ MY RAPPING PART ♪
>> WOW, THAT'S PRETTY MUCH WHAT
I WOULD HAVE SAID, SO THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS TOO
FORWARD, BUT I ACTUALLY HAVE
TICKETS FOR UFC 260 IF YOU GUYS
WANT TO COME.
>> OH, HELL YEAH.
>> YEAH, NO DOUBT.
>> GREAT.
♪ NA NA NA NA NA NA
NA NA NA NA NA NA
NA NA NA NA NA NA ♪
♪ NERDS ♪